st
ja hallo
hallo herr tutorial
wie ist die lage ich habe es gern schon
ein bisschen mitbekommen du wirst auf
der straße erkannt an allen ecken und
enden was ich bei dir faszinierend finde
du bist ja kein aufgebaut dass da
sondern das hat sich in
anführungszeichen so ergeben ganz
genommen habe ich das richtig
zusammengefasst es ist ja genau
zusammengefasst und ja einfach gestartet
auf youtube ein video hochgeladen und
hat seinen lauf genommen
warum ist das bei dir der fall gewesen
bei anderen nicht ich würde einfach mal
denken dass ich videos für die
allgemeinheit macht sie so gestaltet
dass sie unterhaltungswert haben tipps
und tricks beinhalten und einfach ich
selbst bin und da und das ist glaube ich
auch mein
geheimtipp an alle die erfolgreich sein
wollen das heißt nicht verstellen dann
kann es natürlich bleiben ja machen das
andere meinst du dass du wenn du hast ja
wahrscheinlich auch muss hingeguckt
haben vorher was machen die anderen
lieben muss ich das machen ja einige
spieler nehmen wie soll ich sagen ich
könnte sagen ich
würde mal sagen das liegt je nach dem
was man auf youtube ist comedian
director je nach dem muss man sich auch
einer gewissen rolle anpassen und als
guru kann ich einfach natürlich sein und
einfach meine tipps an den mann bringen
ist das dir ein anliegen gewesen deine
tipps oder hast du belegt das ist so
toll youtube da will ich was machen was
war so sehr anfang der idee also ich
wollte schon immer mal videos machen und
dann habe ich auch auf youtube
angeschaut und andere große entdeckt
überwiegend weiblicher und ich habe mir
dann gedacht ein männlicher guru des
werbers und
so denke ich mal was ganz neues für die
für die user auf youtube und
platz wobei du ja tipps auch vor allem
für für die weibliche zuseher schafft
macht zum teil also ich versuche meine
tipps allgemein zu halten männliche und
weibliche user anzusprechen und ich
versuche einfach so ein mittelding zu
finden damit einfach beide seiten
anspricht wie gehst du daran wenn du
jetzt im video macht also ich setze mich
hin überlegt mir was für ein thema
könnte gut ankommen was für ein thema
ist vielleicht gefragt von meinen
zuschauern und ich bin auch im ständigen
kontakt via twitter mit meinen
zuschauern und auf diese weise können
sie mir auch vorschläge machen und die
bezieht dann auch mit ein und so komme
ich oft meine video ideen skripte sie
auch manchmal schreibt mir auch was ich
vielleicht sagen will um einen roten
faden zu verfolgen und
so lange geht sogar an ich sag mal wenn
so ein thema hast nagelpflege dann musst
du ja dieses gebiet irgendwie abarbeiten
da muss ja so du musst ja wirklich
experte dafür werden ja wie genau seine
video ja da habe ich ja zwei schwestern
die kann ich sie sehr gut mit
einbeziehen fragen und tipps und tricks
von ihnen erfahren und auch an meine
zuschauer nun weitergeben mich die auch
manchmal in die bibliothek suche nach
verschiedenen büchern und informiere
mich dann kann man das als journalismus
beschreiben schönheits journalismus
könnte man vielleicht zu sagen weil man
recherchiert ja auch und um möglichst
gute tipps zu machen zwar hast du dir
das dann selber beigebracht ich sag mal
die journalistischen fähigkeiten weil
man wenn man recherchiert eine pflege
man kann in wikipedia google ja aber das
machen viele und dabei sind empfindlich
aber wie vermeidet du wirst ja ich würde
mal sagen
learning by doing selber ausprobieren
selber testen sehen ob diese tipps und
tricks wirklich wirken und ob sich lohnt
die auch an meine zuschauer
weiterzugeben und so vermeide ich fehler
und das heißt was machst du wirklich die
wende ist das auch ganz genau alles was
man bei dir sieht hast du mal an
dieselben approbiert auf eine fälle also
war das unangenehmste das unangenehmste
würde ich mal sagen war
meine café maske ja da hat alles
gekribbelt flecken auf meinem t-shirt
aber das habe ich dann auch im video
gesagt aufpassen wir damit rumhantiert
nicht dass hier flecken ernst diesen
flecken auf eurem tisch erzeugt und hast
du die bereut die kaffee maske oder
eigentlich nicht also die wirkung war
wirklich sehr gut und das feedback von
den zuschauern war auch sehr positiv und
da
habe ich mich auch bestätigt gefühlt
dass es auch wie war das am anfang hast
du dich verändert gegenüber dem anfang
oder anfangs gleich viel schüchterner
vor der kamera zu stehen hier selbst mit
mir zu reden und
mittlerweile ist es für mich ganz normal
an vor der kamera zu stehen im leeren
raum zu stehen und mit mir selber
sozusagen zu reden diese seien immer so
ein bisschen geld neben dir und guckst
auf dich ja ich schaue manchmal weg aus
der kamera um zu überlegen was will ich
jetzt sagen und
es ist ein komisches gefühl für jeden da
damit anfängt aber irgendwann wird man
geht es ja und du sagst du warst
schüchtern warum hast du das dann
gemacht wollte vielleicht die
schüchternheit überwinden das war jetzt
eigentlich nicht dass das war eigentlich
nicht der grund wieso ich mit youtube
angefangen habe das war
man lernt einfach also man wird einfach
vor der kamera selbstbewusstsein und
es ist noch kein meister vom himmel
gefallen würde ich mal sagen und übung
macht den meister ja wobei sie sehen
jetzt du hast zigtausende abonnenten das
geht in die was war deine höchste quote
bisher pro video also
420.000 420.000 wenn man sich blamiert
blamiert man sich vor 420.000 menschen
die es nicht so schön ist
auch aber auch nicht von vielen
akzeptiert dass ein junger gerade im
internet zur pflege tipps gibt und
viele würden sich sowas nicht trauen
weil sie angst hätten sich zu blamieren
aber ich stehe da vollkommen dahinter
und das solange man hinter hinter einer
sache steht kann man sich nicht
blamieren gut aber wir erleben es auch
es gibt hacker ja die und es tut immer
ein bisschen weh also mir tut es immer
man fragt sich auch was habe ich denn
wieso und oder herr das inzwischen an
die rub also ich habe es immer so gesagt
dass hater sozusagen
das ist so ein zitat eines meiner
lieblings zitate hätte sind wie
sandpapier sie können sich an der reiben
sie können sich an mir
zerkratzen aber am ende bin ich der
ausgeschnittene diamant und sie sind
abgeschnitten ist es war nicht die ja
auch was gut ist was ein weiter bringt
ja ich denke ja immer hey ein
händlerkommentar der provoziert ja auch
wieder ganz viele sich das anzugucken
lässt das ist ja wieder das problem also
hinter jedem auch volg stecken hater und
ja wie gehst du mit ihnen um löschte die
oder was machst du also bei mir ist
eigentlich egal also ich lass sie
einfach jeder kommentar ist ein
pluspunkt in der meistdiskutierten ist
ja ich irgendwie ist man lernt es auch
zu ignorieren und dass man das hab ich
mir auch sehr oft selber und das ist
auch mein prinzip schon seit anfang auf
youtube dass man bei ihrer positiven
kommentaren immer auf dem boden bleiben
sollte und behälter kommentaren ist sie
sich einfach nicht an sich ranlassen
man muss da schon sich ein bisschen jan
panzer hofft von wanze aufbauen ganz
genau du hast gerade gesagt hier das ist
ja jeder kommentar ist ein pluspunkt auf
der liste der der kommentare du bist ja
so ein bisschen rekordjäger du sagst
abonniert mich kommentiert michael
stellt fragen an die zuschauer damit
eben auch viele kommentare reinkommen wo
willst du hin
wo ich hin will ich möchte einfach dass
so viele menschen wie möglich spaß an
meinen videos haben dass ihnen dieser
unterhaltungsfaktor geboten ist dass sie
vielleicht ich bekomme viele kommentare
die einfach sagen dass mein tag gerettet
ich hatte heute einen schlechten tag als
ich das video gesehen habe ging es mir
wieder gut und ich möchte das auch
verbreiten diese positive energie die
ich in meinen videos ausstrahle ja gut
dann anders gewarnt wo führt das hin
führt das hin
fürchtet dass hin
zumal ein erfolg ja
das weiß ich nicht und das ist ja gratis
ich weiß nicht was jetzt noch in zukunft
durch diese ganzen youtube geschichte
passieren wird du hast dann nicht
überlegt also wenn jetzt das passiert
mache ich das wenn jetzt das passiert
mache ich das das hast du sag mal endest
du aus oder ich lasse das einfach auf
mich zukommen
genauso wie dieses interview deshalb
jetzt auch nicht erwartet und ja
aber du hast auch ein berufswunsch ja
oder tritt ja immer mehr in den
hintergrund jetzt durch den eigentlich
nicht also ich will immer noch
mtv-moderator ladenschluss zu sagen
ja aber ich baue mir sozusagen meine
eigene zuschauer war es ist auf und das
macht mir immer mehr spaß dieses so der
moderator meine eigene show zu sein du
willst mtv moderatorin beim eine info
war du willst eventmanager werden und
medienmanagement markieren er das hört
sich natürlich auch abgewandelt ich
möchte einfach ich habe gemerkt dass es
mir spaß macht vor der kamera zu stehen
und einfach moderator zu sein einer
meiner lieblings sendungen wer halt dass
die optimale berufswunsch du bist ja
nicht perfekt weil du authentisch ist
und das wird honoriert in der form dass
die leute dich abonnieren die ich gut
finde deine fans sind und dieser summer
perfekte typ von mtv wie wir sie bisher
gesehen haben ist vielleicht gar nicht
mehr gewünscht ja vielleicht bringe ich
was anderes
ja ein paar veränderungen was ist das
denn für einen gefühlten dem moment wo
er merkt verdammt jetzt werde ich hier
wirklich in die öffentlichkeit gespült
ja mag das ja auch immer mehr wenn ich
jetzt auf der straße unterwegs bin dass
mich leute so wie gerade eben also
wieder erkennen und mich ansprechen
manche zuschauer schreien und wollen
fotos mit mir und
das ist ein komisches gefühl aber ich
bleibe noch mal wie ich immer auf dem
boden bleiben wobei es hat sich was für
dich gerne du hast du in deinem letzten
jahres video gesagt du hast vieles
gelernt du hast zum beispiel gelernt
dass aus besten freundin die größten
feinde werden werden gibt es genau und
es ist auch umgekehrt aus den größten
feinden werden plötzlich die besten
freunde das ist dass es das ist bei
jedem erfolg so bei jedem menschen der
erfolg hat da kommen immer falschen
menschen und da muss man auf jeden fall
aufpassen was machst du dann reagiert so
dann musste ich ja demgegenüber auch
verhalten ganz normal also hallo und
tschüss ja und tschüss aber das hätte
vorher vielleicht nicht gesagt sondern
jetzt auch ned das so mich interessant
findest jetzt heißt aber nicht es ist
meine popularität die sie interessant
sind
also kann es nicht beantworten wird zu
sagen ja deswegen schwere frage
schwere frage
unbeantwortet
genau also das werde ich vielleicht noch
lernen um genau unterscheiden zu können
wäre es richtig wäre es falsch
okay ist aber ist natürlich auch eine
schwierigkeit weil
ich habe es gelesen ich weiß nicht ob's
stimmt weil ich kann nicht alle videos
von wir gucken jetzt beziehungstipps
gegeben aber so als wenn wir keine
beziehung ja glaubt genau wo
man lernt auch aus den erfahrungen
anderer würde ich mal sagen und diese
kann nicht super an mein videos umsetzt
aber du kannst sie selber noch nicht
umsetzen nein noch nicht das wird ja
auch immer schwieriger dann im partner
zu finden wo man
wird irgendwann kommen die guten
sind schon gekommen
soll ich sagen es gibt immer welche
wobei ich sie nicht als groupies
bezeichnet das hätte ich ein bisschen
komisch an ich werde also ich versuche
auch so ein verhältnis zu meinen
zuschauern zu haben dass sie meine
zuschauer sind sind nicht nur abonnenten
sind menschen für mich das sind menschen
die selben interessen mit mir teilen und
ich versuche es auch dabei zu lassen ich
will jetzt nicht großartig fans und
groupies in solche worte benutzen
aber es wird irgendwann fanclub
ist es schon auf den verschiedensten
seiten würden dann gibt es die haupt
fans ja die werden auf eine engere
beziehung zu den drängenden ja die gibt
es auch schon
ist ja auch okay man brauchte ja weil
sonst muss man ja mit 50.000 mehr
geräten aber so hat man ebenso 23 mit
jemand er öfter mal gerade genau sind
das so deine ersten abonnenten oder was
sind das für die handy dessen diejenigen
die von anfang an dabei waren und von
denen ich ganz genau weiß die sind immer
dabei egal was kommt sie sind noch so
ein bisschen aus der zeit wo du noch
nicht prominent war wirklich man sagt so
sagen ja genau und von daher ist das
schon mal ein vertrauensverhältnis was
sie aber auch so ist durch diese
tutorials oder dass du eben sagt hier
ich muss mich zeigen wie ich bin das
heißt du zeigst sich hunderttausenden
wie du bist fehlt dir denn nicht
manchmal so ein schutzmann schauspieler
der spielt eine rolle ein moderator
spielt eigentlich auch eine rolle weil
er stellvertretend wir dem zuschauer die
fragen stellt aber du bist du ist das
nicht manchmal zu dicht dran ja klar es
kommt aber immer darauf an also
natürlichkeit jeder kann natürlichkeit
ausstrahlen aber es kommt immer darauf
an was man von sich preisgibt also was
man jetzt von sich gibt und ich denke
dass es jetzt ein großes problem ist
also natürlich kann jeder sein aber
sollten darauf aufpassen nicht zu viel
von sich preiszugeben also das ist
wirklich ganz wichtig da eine grenze zu
ziehen und kommen dann nicht die leute
auch seine positiven und wollen immer
mehr und mehr und mehr ja klar aber dann
sage ich auch einfach dass es viel zu
privat sowas beantworte ich nicht und
das ist verstehen wo ist die grenze
die grenze
die grenze solange man nicht jetzt nicht
preisgibt wo man wohnt oder was die
telefonnummer ist da ist es
ganz okay aber die leute wir sind ja
immer mehr über dich sie wissen dass ich
smi heiße und 19 jahre alt ist und aus
stuttgart kommen und wer nicht wenn wir
alle seine videos waren revue passieren
lässt dass seine schwester hast
gut wir sind nicht was sein vater als
beruf macht oder wissen wir dass nein
bis man nicht was deine mutter machen
wir auch nicht was deine schwester macht
wissen wir auch nicht außer dass ich
außer dass sie singt und und nix also
das ist alles quasi
privatsphäre und würdest du auch nicht
wenn jetzt die yellow press kommt und
sagt wir wollen dringend eine homestory
machen wird so ablehnen ganz genau weil
für mich ist erst dann zu sehr
eingedrungen in meine privatsphäre und
da will ich auch nicht zu nein bin ich
nicht einfach gut sehr vernünftig was
planst du für die zukunft was kann ich
für die zukunft die zukunft steht merke
ich offen das heißt man kann davon
ausgehen dass man sich in 20 jahren noch
auf youtube sie garantiert also solange
ich noch fit und aktiv und so lustig
drauf wenn wie ich jetzt bin ja
garantiert du bist immer so ich bin
immer ganz locker drauf also ja also so
wie ich jetzt erlebe wieder vor der
kamera bist ja ich eigentlich immer ich
bin so ein vater menschlich fragt wozu
sollte ich ein grimmiges gesicht sind
was ist wenn du mal sah war bisher
klar die solche teil gibt es immer aber
es
gibt immer etwas wofür sich zu lachen
lohnt was wäre denn gewesen wenn das
jetzt bei youtube es geklappt hätte was
wäre denn was wäre dann heute dann will
ich jetzt immer noch ein ganz normaler
junge sein der ganz normal sein
zivildienst ableistet und danach
studieren wird klar ich werde immer noch
studieren also youtube ist immer noch
plan b und
man sollte immer was in der hand haben
wie ihr vater über
ok
dann also viel erfolg damit plan a und
plan b gegen dank durchzukriegen judt
dankeschön